nous sommes en 76 quel est Jerry rock de
Londre new-yorkais son album radio
Ethiopia en hommage au voyage de Rimbaud
en Abyssinie Patti Smith pâtisserie
Julien Lepers
messieurs l'homme qui serait le plus
cultivé du monde s'il avait juste un peu
de mémoire donc vous êtes ici ce soir
pour discuter de la situation
Moyen-Orient et de la place de l'islam
dans la République avec Tariq Ramadan
oui bien sûr en fait vous êtes ici ce
soir pour fêter les 25 ans de question
[Applaudissements]
il y a un gâteau qui arrive il y a
quelque chose
là il attend qui arrive il y a quelque
chose
25 ans en plus je voudrais pas non pas
d'alcool pas de cigarette pas de drop
pas de choses comme ça
limite triste limites les chiffres
parlent d'eux-mêmes
7500 émissions 800
000 questions posées
800.000 fois à faire semblant de
connaître la réponse je vois non
heureusement qu'il y a des réponses sur
les cartons parce que
pour un champion en plus c'est à
l'antenne 365 jours par an rediffusez la
nuit
366 les années bissextiles on peut pas
échapper et le dimanche une heure de jeu
une heure alors vous enregistrez six
émissions par jour d'enregistrement
multiplié par 6 jours d'enregistrement
cette fois-ci Thierry voilà bravo alors
ce qui est terrible c'est que des fois
vous avez mal au maxillaire à force
d'articuler c'est vrai j'ai mal aux
pieds j'ai mal au dos parce que je suis
debout moi je suis pas assis
alors le plus gros changement en fait
dans le jeu en 25 ans c'est quand vous
avez décidé de ne pas mettre de cravate
pour les week-ends
des centaines de lettres pas du tout
c'est totalement faux avant non non le
décor le public c'est le même depuis 25
ans
le bac ils sont là
il y en a qui sont là et
le décor a changé la façon de rédiger
les questions à changer la façon de
sélectionner les candidats à changer
évolution oui révolution non alors
incroyable succès audience très stable
sauf peut-être en cas de forte canicule
là vous avez beaucoup de
evidemment ça tombe comme des mouches là
c'est marrant quand même parce que c'est
un jeu où il y a quoi une encyclopédie à
gagner c'est pas du tout non pas du tout
le dimanche à partir de maintenant et ça
c'est nouveau on peut gagner jusqu'à
100000 euros
[Applaudissements]
une grande partie du succès du jeu est
dû à vos gimmicks ah oui oui oui
Julien Lepers
me prendre pour un coup vous êtes une
idole sur France 3e âge
non c'est faux
700000 fans sur les réseaux sociaux
7000 followers sur
Twitter pas du tout en tout cas à la
question qu'aimeriez vous faire avant de
mourir
80% des femmes de plus de 65 ans
répondre faire l'amour avec Julien
Lepers
de donner votre nom à une hanche en
plastique
également l'idole des jeunes
effectivement on regarde quand j'étais
petit je croyais que l'animateur de
Questions pour un champion je vais aussi
dans Batman
top à l'âge de 6 ans je regarde tous les
jours question pour un champion dans les
sports de voir Batman à la place du
présentateur je suis je suis je suis
complètement stupide bonne réponse je
suis complètement stupide
alors évidemment pour rester jeune
Julien pour vous donner beaucoup de mal
non
[Musique]
les gens m'ont pris en charge vraiment
le personnel de médicament change très
très bien son charmant et ce que
j'attends de voir c'est le résultat bien
sûr mais on me dit que le résultat
probant je l'aurai dans 6 mois
franchement c'est bien moi je ne
regrette pas de l'avoir fait et j'ai
quoi j'ai une sorte une cinquantaine
d'années bon bah 50 ans il faut le faire
alors là
explication
comme je voulais voir ce qui était en
train de faire tu sais en je pouvais pas
le voir je lui ai demandé qu'il me fasse
un truc et qui demeure quelqu'un l'a
pris la mission de site et la portée
chez Ardisson
52 millions de vues
merci alors en fait non sérieusement il
faudrait que vous soyez immortel parce
que France 3 n'a que un mois de stock
les cimetières sont pleins de gens
irremplaçables
[Musique]
alors attends attends attends
d'accord au total combien de petits-fils
de Louis XV ont régné sur la France 3
bravo bien joué
[Applaudissements]
attends attends une dernière nous sommes
en 76 quel est Jerry rock de London
ground New Yorkais sur l'album radio
Ethiopia en hommage au voyage de Rimbaud
en Abyssinie Patti Smith pâtisserie
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu